wait we're talking about frozen again ah
can't we just let it go hello Internet
welcome to film theory the icy cold
heart bringing a chill to the Disney
canon a case in point today frozen you
know those movies you love to watch over
the holidays for 7i it's always
Nightmare Before Christmas around
Thanksgiving and then Lord of the Rings
in Disney leading up to Christmas and
with my tryptophan induced napping and
Black Friday shopping behind me it meant
that it was time for my yearly viewing
of frozen and you know what it's still a
really good movie I know it's easy to
hate on it because the overexposure that
it got but in all honesty the characters
are great the songs are great it's
really funny is so dear internet stop
hating unpopular things just be all edgy
and anti culture okay you know I say
that but then you got to consider that a
huge part of this movie's success was
Disney's unwillingness to hate on its
own established ropes so when is saved
by true love's kiss everyone dismisses
the idea of love for site and the dreamy
prince charming turns out to be the
villain but ever since I watched movie
the first time it's always been that
last point that bothered me the most
because for as much as I loved Prince
honza's turned to the dark side in the
final moments of the movie it just felt
like it came out of nowhere and of
course part of that is the point of the
twist it's a surprise like that ream of
printer paper your aunt got you as a
Christmas present at one time man you
think reacting with enthusiasm to an
ugly Christmas sweater is hard try that
one but if you actually stop to watch
honza's behavior and the flow of this
plan throughout the movie nothing adds
up which means either a disney writers
knew they wanted a big twist news hubs
the shuffle pieces around without much
concern over how it played into its
larger character arc or me there's
something much more sinister going on in
this world and while a is probably the
factual correct choice B is the more fun
choice it to be that means it's the
right choice so let's dedicate an
episode to unearthing the secret
conspiracy that clears honza's name once
and for all let's first look at his
motive for this big murder plot he says
himself as thirteenth in line in my own
Kingdom I didn't stand a chance I knew
I'd have to marry into the throne
somewhere which on the surface would
seem to make sense he wants to rule a
kingdom and he sees an opportunity with
arendelle marry one of the two
princesses and boobies at the running to
be wearing the crown and it gives us a
little bit more detail in his next line
as heir Elsa was preferable of course
but no one was getting anywhere with her
but you you were so desperate for love
you were willing to marry me just like
that so option one is marry Elsa
fast-track your way up to the royal
throne but since she tends to give
people a bit of the old cold shoulder I
don't hear your raucous laughter so let
me shout it louder
cold shoulder he went for the next best
thing
Anna next in line to be queen should
Elsa die and he knows this I figured
after we married I'd have to stage a
little accident for Elsa which anyone
who's ever heard an evil monologue
before doz means giving her the old
stabbed and a half thrown her in front
of a rogue snowplow or the classic
bloodless Disney death of just throwing
her off a tall cliff she's gone and onna
with Hans in tow ascent to the throne
I'll bet stuff now is to kill Elsa and
bring back summer and this is the moment
where things start to go off the rails
so his plan involves killing Elsa he is
so enthusiastic about it he mentions it
twice in that little monologue we just
went over and yet when he and the guards
come to Elsa's ice palace looking for
Anna Hans expresses his intention to do
the exact opposite protect Elsa we are
here to find Princess Anna be on guard
but no harm is to come to the Queen
later in the scene when a guard
literally has else in his crosshairs
Hans runs over and diverts the shot if
he truly wants Elsa dead I don't let the
guard kill her right then and there I
mean maybe he just really liked that
snowplow idea but seriously with life
hands you lemons you shoot a crossbow
bolt through the heart of the woman
standing between you and the throw
Hamas's hands would be clean into the
rest of the world including Anna who
just got herself ice blasted by dear
ol sis Elsa is a threat a monster but
not only does he divert the shot he also
offers her a nice bit of hashtag Monday
motivation don't bring a monster they
fear you are puns is this what you say
to the person you have a murder plot
against he's helping her to become a
better person seriously she is on the
verge of murdering people and that's no
exaggeration look at this guard being
shoved off the balcony by her ice wall
had it not been for Hans she would have
literally killed this man Disney's most
beloved princess be killing some peeps
up in this icy kids house the script
even confirms it Hans his line causes
her to snap out of her rage so why why
would you help the woman you plan to
eventually bump off when the problem
solves itself right then and there in
that moment and then again when they
bring Elsa back to arendelle and put her
in prison he says once more why did you
bring me here I couldn't just let them
kill you he's doing it to win honest
trust I hear you say but that's not it
either
she's already convinced she's in love
with him in just a few scenes she'll be
begging for hugs to kiss her Hans you
have to kiss me what now and all through
the troll song both Kristoff and Otto
continually assert that she's already a
taken woman rejecting the idea that
there's any sort of romance there and
here's the other thing
Hans is already in charge of arendelle
throughout most of the movie when anna
decides to run off and bring back elsa
she puts him in charge I'm coming with
you I need you here to take care of
arendelle I leave Prince Hans in charge
let's face it
Otto is just a few days away from rising
to the throne based on the sisters talk
the ice castle
has zero intention of returning to the
city back home your life awaits go enjoy
the Sun open up again I'm alone but I'm
alone
she's willingly abdicated the throne
she's saying that Audino has the power
to keep the gates open because she's the
new decision-maker Anna is going to be
the queen Elsa is happier alone at the
top of the mountains in her Fortress of
Solitude even when she escapes prison
where she running to her safe space ice
castle
so all homs has to do to accomplish his
goal is to not suck for the few days
that Ana's away comfort her a bit when
she returns home depressed that Elsa is
now ruling a private snowman Kingdom and
you know make sure that his future wife
doesn't die that's all he has to do in
order to achieve the goal that he is set
out to achieve literally do nothing all
the murder plots all the bringing Elsa
back from the ice castle none of it
matters but that last task is important
because let's actually talk about his
refusal to kiss Anna so recap on his
heart has been frozen over by Elsa's ice
powers she's about to die it needs an
act of true love in order to save her
she thinks that this will be a kiss from
Hans because she's a Disney character
who was raised on Disney movies
apparently but he refuses making it
clear that he never loved her at all all
he wanted to do was marry her for her
kingdom he puts out the candles so
she'll freeze to death faster and then
leaves prematurely because every villain
always leaves prematurely except it
makes zero sense there is literally no
reason not to kiss her in this situation
if she lives great he's able to be
married to her and rise to power at her
side like his plan always intended in
the first place if the kiss doesn't work
well she dies and he can still play the
whole marriage charade off just like he
does in the actual movie except with
someone who is literally dead and can't
show up a few seconds later to disprove
everything that he just said in fact if
he truly cares about his goal then he
chose the riskiest move he could have
because letting on a die puts it in
serious jeopardy if she doesn't make it
his whole plan
balsa farms to really understand why
though we have to quickly talk about
monarchies so I've been binge-watching
the crown on Netflix and doing a bunch
of research on royal succession you know
since my chances of being elected
president here in the United States is
getting pretty slim these days and hey
my rule a United States when you can
rule a United Kingdom anyway if
arendelle is like most monarchies Homs
would have to keep Anna alive in order
to help her rule the kingdom is he in a
typical monarchy like having Great
Britain the crown gets passed around
based on the royal blood running through
your veins so if the king or queen dies
the new ruler is the oldest child
that's why elsa becomes queen her
parents die maybe but more on that later
so when she's of age he has sends to the
throne
she's now the oldest blood relative if
elsa abandons the throne or gets herself
thrown in front of that snowplow and has
no little olaf's of her own it goes to
the next in line
Anna and that is what Han should be
counting on but if Anna dies like she is
literally minutes away from doing when
Hans decides to go all rogue he doesn't
just remain on the throne and get to
rule because of blood let me explain
although many people consider every King
to have a queen and vice versa that's
not really the way it works the one who
possesses the royal blood is called the
monarch that's the one who's in charge
they're sexy spent in the sheets then is
known as their royal consort and are in
no way in line for the throne for an
example just look at the British line of
succession the Queen's husband phillup
isn't even in the top fifty when it
comes to waiting in line for the throne
mrs. Irina Walker Kruger who lives in
the US is more likely to become the next
British monarch and she is currently on
probation for being associated with
illegal gambling and cockfighting that
is no joke that person is more likely to
become the Queen of England then fill up
the current Queen's husband and based on
how we see the monarchy handoffs
happening in frozen arendelle would
operate the same way Hans wouldn't even
get the title of King in his plan just
like a deck of cards the royal consort
can't have a title that beats the actual
monarch so if Anna is the Queen Hans
can't be the king it's the higher title
so instead Hans would always have to
remain Prince Hans
royal consort to Queen Anna it's
actually the same thing in Britain right
now Queen Elizabeth is the reigning
monarch and her husband is
phillup even though he's the prince
who's currently 95 years old so you see
the crown would go to literally anyone
with a drop of blood related to these
two and Hans has zero arendelle Ian's
blood get this when it comes down to it
Tarzan would be next in line
it sounds like a joke but interviews
with the creators of frozen have
confirmed that Anna and Elsa's parents
do survive their shipwreck and give
birth to Tarzan before of course they
die from that grisly leopard attack man
first a shipwreck then mulled by a
leopard guess that's what you get for
stifling your child's ice magic karma is
brutal if not Tarzan well then based on
the other theories about the movie
including my last film theory about it
Rapunzel could also be up for ruler of
arendelle regardless if Tom's has any
hope of preserving a royal title and
ruling the kingdom in any way he needs
Anna alive thinking his evil turn here
in the final minutes of the movie makes
zero sense but lastly let's just dial it
back and look at how this guy behaves
when Anna leaves him in charge of the
kingdom he spends his time giving cloaks
out to people who are cold the castle is
open there is soup and hot glogg in the
Great Hall he threatens to throw the
duke of weaseltown weselton
in jail on the charge of treason against
Anna and Elsa I will not hesitate to
protect arendelle from treason
but the Duke complains about how
dangerous Elsa is Hans corrects him
saying you slipped on ice even in the
very beginning of the movie look at them
look at each other
that's genuine affection and when Hans
gets knocked into the water a few
seconds later and is hidden under the
boat he smiles to himself not an evil
grin or sinister sneer it's just one of
those lovestruck goofy grins in short if
this is the guy who wants to rule
arendelle and kill Elsa it's just not
doing a good job of it what's even
stranger is that if there is a rosin to
the writers intend on giving Hans a
Redemption arc no joke they're like no
no we have an idea I want to bring you
back wanna redeem no other Disney
villain has ever gotten that sort of
treatment so what
gives here well what if Hans was just a
pawn in someone else's game collateral
damage for another groups agenda what if
there's another villain in frozen
no not Sven not even the duke of
weaseltown it's Olaf nope no it's not
Olaf that would be stupid the true
villains and frozen are trolls you heard
me those comes in low rocks that are
just randomly shoved into the movie may
just be the ones with the evil intent
now that may seem like a stretch hear me
out here let's start with their song
fixer-upper which at first seems like a
light-hearted comedy song but when you
actually bother to pay attention to the
lyrics they contain some really
disturbing lines like I mentioned
earlier Kristoff is very upfront about
Anna already being engaged to Hans she's
engaged to someone else okay and yet
despite this the trolls steamroll past
that little detail saying her quote
engagement is a flex arrangement and get
the fiancee out of the way and the whole
thing will be fixed by the end of the
song the trolls are literally trying to
trick Allah in to marry and Kristoff
take Kristoff to be your trough Allah
willing
what you're getting married hopefully
ignoring that she probably doesn't want
to kiss a guy who literally eats carrots
that came out of his reindeers mouth but
why would they push so hard to see these
two married well remember Kristoff was
adopted by the trolls as part of the
clan so having one of their own be a
part of the noble family is a huge deal
especially when the nobles think you'll
look like this some pretty sinister
looking imagery right there just saying
also ask yourself this who are the first
ones to scare Elsa about her powers the
trolls prior to visiting them Elsa was
confident in her abilities the only
reason Anna gets injured at the top of
the movie is because she was reckless
leaving Elsa as the one who has to take
all the blame what have you done and yet
with mom frozen and dad frozen take
their daughters to see good old
grandpappy what's the solution he does
the following I recommend we remove all
magic
even memories of magic to be safe remove
all magic he said huh did Otto ever have
powers too strange anyway let me put
that one on the old list of potential
theories to look into regardless what
does raising Ana's memories do nothing
well at least nothing good
she becomes alone and alienated from a
sister for reason she can't fathom
meanwhile Elsa's pushed into a kingdom
of isolation where it looks like she's
the queen heavy blue ribbon over here
also ensures that Elsa is terrified of
herself must learn to control it fear
will be your enemy you sure about that
grandpa heavy you're gonna say that fear
is the ultimate enemy and then punctuate
the moment by doing what now scaring her
with a spooky vision all right cool
good on you to quote the script the
spikes turn into human form which then
attack the silhouette of adult Elsa this
frightens Elsa fear is going to be your
enemy whoa gotcha good one grand pabbie
the worst jump scare ever should put you
into faff sister location custom nights
all of this even though once again Elsa
was fine and had perfect control of her
powers before this visit what else do
the trolls do oh yeah they willfully
mislead Anand
thinking that she needs true love's kiss
to survive her frozen heart despite them
being love experts and also completely
wrong a true love's kiss perhaps but
here's the big problem grand pabbie is
really good at manipulating people's
minds and he does it all the time sure
in frozen we only see it done once to
Anna which as I said accomplishes
nothing good but then in Once Upon a
times frozen themed sees and we see him
do it again and this time on a much
larger and much more catastrophic scale
when Goethe eventual queen of arendelle
and mother of Anna and Elsa traps her
sister in a magical urn because that
sister killed her other sister worst day
ever Jessica's grand pabbie for help
requesting that he erased the memories
of the entire kingdom of arendelle to
never remember her two sisters and
pabbie he just doesn't he puts up no
resistance requests no payment he's just
like alright let's create some fake
memories in these peasants and then he
even
to cover it up when Ana asks him about
the incident he hides the fact that it
was Ana's mother who requested the
memory wipe in the first place he's
protecting a legacy of lies
what's the say that the trolls couldn't
or wouldn't do some sort of memory magic
on Hans fiance who just happens to be in
the way of their big plans for Kristoff
remember what the trolls say over and
over again the head can be persuaded but
the heart is not so easily changed
long story short honza's plan makes zero
sense especially considering all the
steps he makes counter to it earlier in
the movie all he needed was that final
kiss and he was locked in making his
turn to be the villain in that final
moment of the movie the complete
antithesis of what he was looking to
accomplish but it does make sense if you
consider the trolls wanted to throw that
fiance away and get Christoph inserted
in his place they've shown themselves to
have the means to manipulate
unsuspecting innocent minds the cunning
to conceal their deeds and the
motivations to trick people into getting
what they want
maybe the redemption arc the writers
have planned for Hans and frozen to was
less about a bad guy turning good but
rather a good guy getting to reveal the
true villains acting behind the scenes
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and guts
[Music]